this altitude I can run flat out for a
half mile before my hands start shaking
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by Vimeo Pro which is the ideal
video hosting platform for entrepreneurs
and in fact a bunch of my startups
already use Vimeo Pro including
wealthfront who uses it to explain how
wealthfront works TaskRabbit uses it to
tell their company's story and there are
many other names you would recognize
among their customers Airbnb Etsy etc
why do they use it well Vimeo Pro
provides enterprise level video hosting
for a fraction of the usual cost
features include gorgeous high quality
playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week unlimited
plays and views and a fully customizable
video player which can include your logo
custom outro etc you also get VIP
support and you get all of this for just
$1.99 per year that's $17 a month with
no complicated bandwidth calculations or
hidden fees and you can try it risk-free
for 30 days so check it out Vimeo com
forward slash business that's VI m EO
com forward slash business and use promo
code Tim to get 25% off that's a special
discount just for you guys so check it
out
Vimeo com forward slash business promo
code Tim this episode is brought to you
by athletic greens I get asked all the
time if you could only use one
supplement what would it be and my
answer is inevitably athletic greens it
is your all-in-one nutritional insurance
I recommended it in the 4-hour body did
not get paid for that and I travel with
it to avoid getting sick I take it in
the mornings to ensure optimal
performance it just covers all my bases
if I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day and you can get 50 oh my gosh 50%
off yes 50% off if you go to athletic
greens com forward slash Tim that's
athletic greens com forward slash Tim
check it out it's tasty but more
important it will help you not
you up when you're doing your
nutritional planning so for me just
covers the bases takes a load off my
mind puts a lot in my body and check it
out athletic greens calm forward-slash
tip hello ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where each
episode it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers to tease out the
habits routines morning rituals favorite
books etc that have made them
spectacularly good at what they do and
there are patterns so that you notice
across disciplines that is why I
interview people from a very broad
spectrum of areas like the military
entertainment chess sports comedy etc so
it ranges from Arnold Schwarzenegger to
General Stanley McChrystal and now in
this episode we have a dynamic duo we
have Seth Rogan at Seth Rogen ROG Iain
who is an actor writer producer and
director and his partner in crime Evan
Goldberg at Evan Dee Goldberg on the
Twitter's who is a Canadian director
screenwriter and producer together they
get into a whole lot of mischief and
create some amazing comedy I had a
chance to spend some time with both
these great gents as well as their team
which is spectacular and I won't mention
the location in case they're keeping
that quiet but here's some background
they've collaborated on films such as
super bad which they actually first
conceived of as teenagers knocked up
pineapple Express the Green Hornet and
funny people they've also written for
the Ali G show and The Simpsons in 2013
Evan and Seth released their directorial
debut this is the end which was actually
a combination of two different ideas we
get into that in the conversation in
2014 Seth starred in and produced
alongside Evan neighbors which was a
worldwide comedy hit and has taken in
more than 268 million worldwide and then
appearing in the news yet again in
December 2014 Rogen and Goldberg film
the interview became easily the most
talked-about news story around the world
and that was not just in the
entertainment mags but in every
different publication because of many
reasons so under extremely difficult
circumstances the film persevered to
become Sony Pictures number one
title of all time neighbors - is
shooting right now and will be released
next May Seth and Evan are also in
production on sausage party which I saw
a clip of a prelim clip which is a
raunchy animated movie for adults about
one sausages quest to discover the truth
about his existence and I really hope to
god that some of the raunchy scenes make
it in because they will make your head
explode Seth and Evan are producing that
film with Megan Ellison and Conrad
Vernon in our conversation the one
you're about to listen to we discuss all
manner of tactics and silliness
including kioku shin karate
empty hand and how they participated in
that writer's block and related debates
does it exist does it not exist how do
you contend with it if it does writing
process I ask questions like who are the
most underrated comedians and comedy
writers what is the odd book that Judd
Apatow recommended to them which happens
to also be Woody Allen's favorite how
super bad got made after they first
drafted around age 13 how kids in the
hall influenced them the movie they both
wish they'd written common pot mistakes
so if you're just listening to this for
a marijuana playbook well there might be
something in here for you as well so
recommended noob pot for working versus
relaxing and much much more so I really
hope you enjoy this as always if you're
not getting my five bullet Friday and
newsletter check it out it is a very
very popular it's just a short email
with a lot of tactical stuff gets sent
out every Friday you can check that out
for our work week com forward slash
Friday that's all spelled out for our
work week com forward slash Friday or
just go to for our work week comment
enter your email there and for all the
show notes for this episode all the
links etc just go to four hour work week
comm and click on podcast so without
further ado please enjoy my conversation
with Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg
Evan Seth welcome on the show thank you
thanks for having us
I appreciate you guys taking the time
especially in this very busy busy month
that you gents have and I thought we
could start with a story that we
discussed a little bit Evan in the car
which was kyoka [ __ ] so tell me about
your crow about when we were kids how we
behaved and how I was a softie and so I
did rugby in karate to cut tried and
toughen myself up and I joined at the
Jewish Community Center which is one of
the places we became really good friends
yes I've been doing it a few years
before me yeah we'd already met in Bar
Mitzvah class and our parents were like
a Jewish community center that can't be
much you know just simple karate and
they let us beat the living [ __ ] was
pretty I realized like we were the bad
guys from Karate Kid you had the cut we
were a Cobra Kai yeah like we were
banned from Turner banned from
tournaments and then we finally went to
a tournament and I realized that like
the way they taught us to fight like was
not conducive to tournament fighting and
I punched a guy in the throat and got
disqualified what you were supposed to
do supposed to be Shinto respond yeah
like that I have a memory of one time
where they made me fight that like 35
year old when I was 14 and she like
choked me out on the ground until I
passed this was in class yeah like full
grown men too I remember hitting that
guy rod so hard my rod was like a 280
pounds 6 foot 3 guy and he was like 40
and I hit him so hard in the face with
like a spinning back hand that he like
knocked him in like almost knocked about
it like dazed him completely and then
they let me then they like they let him
fight me again that he like punched me
in the mouth so hard I like couldn't I
couldn't like I think my mouth started
bleeding and then I hurt them then but
there's so many stories that are
flooding is the day that ended it all
where I got kicked in the hip by a 40
year old black belt who fractured my hip
yeah and then he backed up into a pillar
and got a piece of wood lodged in his
foot and thus ended our Kyoshi
but I remember fighting the teacher on
the ground one time like the teacher
Sean with like I remember like grappling
on the ground with him I was like trying
to bite him I was like that was you're
supposed to do yeah
so you mentioned coaxing you're like I
don't think you know people get the
wrong image when I tell them karate and
I from having lived in Japan for a year
as an exchange student his first time I
got exposed to kill question and those
were like the bad boys of the karate
world it was very well known like you
don't want to get the leg kicks were
very famous yeah legs the entire yeah
and I and he just like kept kicking my
legs out from under me relentlessly and
there was nothing I can be made all of
us watch as he did it to him for like
yeah just like I just like would get up
in it like try to fight again it he
would just like smack my legs out from
under me and just like our members like
hitting the ground if there's one guy
the guy who ended up fracturing my hip
which ruined my rugby and karate
watching your hip is not a small
hairline fracture it wasn't terrible but
it's enough that I couldn't run and
stuff like that
Malcolm you know do this thing to this
day I can't comprehend how he did it in
a movie you wouldn't believe it
he literally like casually put both
hands behind his back you know small
room area try and hit me yeah and I
couldn't and I'm like fifteen sixteen
real fit I've been doing karate for like
five years and I couldn't even touch him
yeah I remember Malcolm kicked me in the
eye once so hard at that my parents had
to call their family friends who were I
daughters and take
their house after the karate class cuz I
like couldn't see out of one of my eyes
like three hours nothing I regret
nothing either it's weird it's weird out
cuz I'm so I was always like not a
violent person I'm not competitive and I
don't like care about MS did it turn you
guys off of that type of thing sort of
indefinitely that's the point
certainly as somebody who has like TMJ
and like has had some joint issues I can
identify that that is too brutal like
their knuckles were all puffed up and
because we would break boards and if you
didn't break the board you had to try
again put a knuckle into it sounds like
a liability Night Watch sometime but
they thought I don't think anyone had a
frame of reference maybe so they just
thought like oh that's a crummy glasses
just pick me up and like yeah not
comment that I was bleeding from some
you know my parents would come sometimes
because I start when I was younger so
they like knew I didn't feel like over
for 10 years or something like from 7:00
in unit 3 yeah I think I started yeah I
do and we did it with our buddy
Fogle and our buddy Korver and our buddy
glands Berg and they would just make us
as friends beat the [ __ ] out of each
other yeah it was pretty glands burger
was soft
he was probably feel pretty good yeah
hey when did you guys first meet I mean
first encounter each other uh it was I
was going to I went to like two hours of
afterschool Hebrew school Tuesday
Thursday and he went to like a half
Hebrew school half normal school he was
pretty much like it was like a Hebrew
school it was like they did half and
half studies but it was like a full-on
like Jewish a woman and he would get out
when I would go in and I would I'd took
the class at the synagogue which was
beside his school so we would see each
other for years we didn't really know
each other yeah but we would Saturday
and I was kind of like the laude from
this side and he was we were friends
with full role I became will yet this
guy Sammy Fogle who's the mclovin of
Superbad yeah really that big loser we
just met
he and I became good friends and sets
mother and his mother were good friends
and then it all kind of culminated to
bar mitzvah class yeah we all took
Sunday morning was it called poem to
fill holes in to fill in class where
they give us chocolate milk and bagels
to lure to learn how to do our Bar
Mitzvah portion it had departments for
Class B giving yeah it's a weird mix but
it's delicious yeah and and we just kind
of met there and because of Fogle we
became friends yeah and when did you
guys start collaborating creatively in
hindsight like eight months later yeah
twelve thirteen it was literally and
it's not like we pretend we don't
remember we don't remember but we were
watching some crappy movie and we just
looked at each other and were like we
could write a better movie it was like a
pause it's like we should write a better
movie and I think I would you stand up
already at that point and so like there
was some context for like we can write
things and they'll become things like I
was already like writing things and then
performing them so it wasn't it wasn't
just like - like we actually like wanted
to make a movie I think it wasn't him
and then I'd already seemed like oh you
can tangibly like do something and a lot
of people you know you came all the way
from Canada and it's not like like
Vancouver's a movie town
yeah the movies at our high school like
one from Silver City than almost anyone
that we know in America City and where
they made tons of movies and so you
would see movie sets everywhere growing
up and our high school they shot a lot
of movies and Diamond Phillips movie
masterminds turn imaginary Patrick
Stewart and Vincent Kartheiser it's not
a fantastic movie but it was shot at our
high school and and so you would see it
around and so it was like it was kind of
no we didn't know anyone in the business
or anything like that
or who was involved in movies but it was
just like around and so yeah kind of my
first interaction is our friend Emilio
Wasserman's mother produced like kids
shows and she like let me try to write
some kids episodes it gave me some balls
they judge mrs. dad like produce TV
shows or something like that I can't
remember like we knew people whose
parents like had like kind of like you
know jobs and like it was around it was
just
around yeah and then uh this girl I
dated a B Saltzburg her mother was a
writer for the newspaper and she kind of
gave me some pointers and helped me out
so we had like some help but we didn't
really have a hard in I think one of my
distant distant cousins was a producer
in passenger 57 the Wesley Snipes that I
remember hearing is a child so you're
given the opportunity to kind of tinker
in the writing perspective with with
these episodes when I grew up next to
the the Jen who created the chooser an
adventure book so we had my brother and
I put our names into the books you guys
is it true you started working on super
bed around that time and started that
that was the first thing we ever tried
to do was writing she was ready to pay
and it was it was terrible at first but
it was really bad at first but um but
that being said we liked movie so much
and we're so into movies that like
looking back we kind of instinctually
like understood the vague structure of
movies in like a pretty instinctual way
and like the baby who loved bad movies
which I think actually was extremely
beneficial yeah not to do tons of
b-movie there was this place called
videomatic that was called there was
seven movies for seven dollars for seven
days yeah it was great and we would go
and do that and watch them all yeah yeah
and it was you know get like two good
movies and five crappy but then around
this time was when movies like pulp
fiction and clerks and like that like
like Rushmore and Bottlerocket like it
was kind of like the dawn of like 90s
independent cinema and we were really
really into those movies too and again a
lot of those movies
you know at least in theory had an in
myth had kind of like a do-it-yourself
feel we're lucky heaven Smith to clerks
especially it's clearly like they just
got a camera there's made a bunch of
friends were like let's [ __ ] do this
and yet and that was very like
inspirational to us because it just
seemed very achievable you know and so I
think that's one of the reasons we again
started doing it it was just like we're
like he was about high school kids we
knew high school kids I wanted to be an
actor we knew there was other kids in
our school who were trying to be actors
and stuff like that and so it just kind
of seemed like we like if we write a
high school movie we could make a high
school movie basically yeah and he had
his stand up start and for me it was
like when I was like five years old if
you asked me what I wanted to do was be
a writer I always wanted to be a writer
they actually sent me to a psychiatrist
in elementary school because I would
write like dark stuff was my at Hebrew
school I learned about the Holocaust and
I kept writing about the Holocaust and
they thought they were something wrong
with me but I don't we met he was like
the first person I ever met who like
wrote recreationally other than me like
I wrote stand-up and he wrote like
stories and stuff like that and I
remembered like when you're like a 13
year old kids who's like what are their
hobbies is writing no it's not that
common and so he kind of made me realize
what the stand-up he was like like he
just did it
and so we both were like what if we just
did this no one at this age is trying to
do it so if we get a jump on it maybe
we'll do okay and also it seemed like
the easiest path to becoming a writer
like I tried to write a novel once and I
failed it is really hard yeah and it is
funny you mentioned the the school
psychologist so I was sent to the school
psychologist also everyone is I was
forced to do writing as I as I didn't
want to do and so thumb Attica Lee I
would turn them into stories about
serial killers
I wrote a dystopian future story about a
bunch of kids trying to get out of a
Nazi controlled future and it ended with
all of them dying you invented the young
adult novel yeah because I drew the
picture of all their corpses nice that's
it that's a nice touch
yeah for those people who wouldn't ache
the time to read it what was the
difference before you set then in the
early days between what were the biggest
differences between writing for stand-up
and this could be contemporary like in
general
and writing for film for instance I
thought about it a lot and when we
started writing movies I honestly like
and when we started doing it more I kind
of became less interested in writing
stand-up in some ways because like and I
honestly think that good standup I
wasn't the best stand-up comedian is one
thing like I would I was pretty good I
was like a b-plus stand-up comedian a -
I wasn't like an a-plus stand-up
comedian and I'm not saying that we're
like the best script writers in the
world but we've achieved a plus moments
I think here and there and so that that
was one of the things I was just took
aware of I would just like watch other
people do it and be like wow this guy's
like doing something like that I like
he's they're just better you know and
when we started writing movies I started
to feel like oh like we act like this I
feel like we could maybe again like
really carve out our own niche doing
which I didn't feel like I was
particularly doing to extent if I was
young and that was at first in each is
like I would write about my young
person's experience but then as I got
older I found like I don't know as a
stand-up I was struggling a little bit
to find a unique perspective I have a
theory you cease to be tortured yeah
exactly that was part of it I was like
really tortured when I was I mean I was
a stand-up comics function largely not
all of them but a lot of them on anxiety
self-obsession that much yeah I don't
find myself that interested one of the
other things is like I and I think
writing and that's one of the reasons I
think writing movies was was better is
because I was writing other people and I
also struggled with stand-up is that you
can only really and again good stand-ups
do this but I couldn't find a way to do
it is like I can only talk from one
perspective in standup but in a movie
you can write two or three or four or
five or six perspectives all in one
scene you could have five guys arguing
there about how to you know turn you
know how to do anything what's the best
way to get out of this room you know and
to and and as we started writing like
you know some of the best scenes that
we've ever achieved are literally just
people screaming at each other and so
like I think that was something that I
thought was very funny that we were good
at was like conflict and it's hard to
have like conflict in stand-up comedy
for me I couldn't find a way to do it
other people do it and they tell stories
that involve conflict and the whole
thing is about you know the struggle and
I look at it now and sometimes I think
like man if I kept doing it I maybe
would have broken through a wall but I
just I don't know and and I loved movies
that was the other thing it's just like
and I loved movies also but I did it
more of a comic nerd he was a comic nerd
too but I was like extreme comic meaning
comic book yeah yeah my brother is a
like natural speed reader he reads it at
a remarkable pace he can read a book in
a day like a 400 page book just burned
through it so he would read comics and
mountains of them would form and then he
would draw them so I would mimic him
because he was 2 years older and I would
read all the comics he read and then try
to draw like him he's actually an expert
he's a very good artist he drew all the
penises for Superbad yeah in the Big
Lebowski
he's a lawyer now but uh I tried to like
mimic him with that stuff and and comics
are just movie storyboards real career
cinematic and I read I love comic books
- I think that's it I mean it's like we
connected heavily over Calvin and Hobbes
yeah we love one of the best of all time
yeah the sarcasm of it like forged our
genius but I think we just liked like
the cinematic like again comics and like
it just seemed appealing and again I
think yeah and it's funny that at the
time like like if you look at what we've
done recently like we like grandiose
things we like big things to happen end
of the world scenarios and all that but
at the time all we knew was that we
really wanted to get laid
we weren't getting laid yeah then we
weren't super cool and I think the
reason super bad worked out is it's rare
that you are the thing you're writing on
at the moment you're doing it right
yourself aware of it yeah
and we're still I mean and we've that's
something that we've continued to try to
do honestly I mean neighbors you know
it's a very good example all I find for
having our friends or having kids or
trying to have kids and are married and
they're getting older and are moving
into different places and like I don't
have a kid and I want to go out and I
call my friends and exactly and so I
think from the get-go and that's
something that came from stand-up comedy
like there's a comic named Darrell
Lennox who still performs who is great
and he the comics were very nice to me
which is in retrospect insane because I
would not be nice to like a 13 year old
kid who was doing stand-up comedy I
don't think maybe I would but I
understood my would but I remember he
saw me perform and I used to have like
jokes I would try like mimic other
comedians like Stephen Wright or
Seinfeld like what's the view of Krazy
Glue and he was like he was like dude
you're like the only 14 year old he's
like you're the only person here who
could like talk about try to get like a
[ __ ] for the first time like talk
about that like that is like so much
more interesting than anything you're
talking about like why are you just
talking about that and I was like oh
you're right that's actually a very good
way
and then that kind of carried through
everything right anyway you know yeah
and yeah that's it it's I've been really
fascinated just sort of observing you
guys work and you know realizing at
least for me when you get started super
bad at a time when those all those
feelings were very kind of ever-present
in your lives and when I look back and
say past books people have asked me like
what would you edit what would you
change and I don't want to touch it
because I feel like it was written at a
very precise point in time or they do
very specific pains that I might not be
experiencing now because it's you know
the chapters passed on what what does
your writing process look like now a lot
of people have asked me to ask you both
this but what is just from the the very
first sort of concept stages well as I
was telling you earlier it's changed a
little we just did this project preacher
with a guy named Sam Catlin right which
I've seen bad yeah and and we used to
immediately start like kind of we would
always write down ideas and he taught us
this new trick of not writing down ideas
for a good month and just shooting it
around and talking and talking and
talking and I kept saying like now we're
gonna write right and he was like no no
no we just keep talking and that's a new
trick that I think was great just spend
way more time talking about it laughter
he said in Breaking Bad they would do is
just like before they did anything they
were just talking talk and talk and it's
something actually like we didn't
declared when I look back at it it's
like we're just anxious to get going I
think sometimes but but I feel like now
I mean and it's kind of always been this
way in that like we'll come up with
ideas and it's like sometimes it it's
like it's there's almost like a
Darwinistic process it's like it's a
round a year later or so like if it's
something we're still talking about
sometimes years later there's some I
mean like there's this movie that were
talking about writing I was going
through old files like the first one
from like 2011 or something like that
example this is the end we had two
separate ideas one was a movie about the
apocalypse another one was celebrities
playing themselves in a disaster type
scenario both of those ideas survived
for four or five years yeah and they
slowly we realized if we merge these
things it's going to be a good citizen
and
and that was that's the perfect example
like we we you know we just be sitting
around working on whatever and be like
what's Apocalypse yeah or just what we
talk about like I mean it's it's like
you know we like what we do and it's fun
for us to think about it's organically
we just be sitting there doing something
else and that's the thing we would just
start joking around about you know and
then if it sticks around then it at
least means that we like is like like
lately I've been obsessed with
artificial intelligence and we're not
writing anything about that but in a
year from now if I'm still talking about
it
maybe that's happen so when you have
something that's really persistent like
that and you have say the celebrities
playing playing themselves in the end of
the world and you're like you know this
could be really interesting if we
combine these two things at the time not
necessarily now that you have the input
from the Breaking Bad writer on that
approach but what were the next steps
you guys took once you were like you
know what let's let's try to pull the
trigger on this we took this a really
long time to figure out how to do it
honestly like that was one of those
movies where bizarrely it just took us
like we could think of the first three
two acts of the movie and then we
couldn't figure out how to end the movie
and it'll just like a year and a half I
think until we thought of the idea that
they realize they can still redeem
themselves basically which is what
allows the third act to happen which is
they're all start trying to redeem
themselves and and we just didn't think
of that and it was literally just like
we couldn't do it I mean while we're
working on other stuff and doing it's
not like we're just sitting in a room
for a year and a half their heads
against the walls like we're still doing
things but that it's like I mean in that
example it literally just took us a
really long time to come up with the
idea that allowed the movie to to
function and then once we thought of
that idea I when we wrote the first
drafted this is the end in like nine
days or something like that
no that was all three acts or just yeah
the whole we wrote the whole movie like
the whole first 120 pages we wrote the
whole script we sat about should be said
we had an extensive outline yeah because
we've been kicking it around for years
and like one thing we do a lot of our
movies are kind of genre based
especially lately you know pineapple
express and this is the end and the
interview to some degree and
something we do is just watch tons of
movies in that genre and so like with
this the end we just watched tons of
these like horror movies and apocalypse
movies and movies about isolation and
kind of little groups of people that are
stuck together and as we do that we just
are jockeying around and coming up with
ideas oh it would be funny if we we send
the guy out on a rope it's like oh they
need water and you just kind of pick up
these themes in the movies yeah like
when Craig Robinson went out of the
house with a rope that was based off of
the mist exactly right and part of it I
mean and we talked a lot about of it is
like really trying to like have our cake
and eat it too in these movies like it's
like we are kind of like mocking the
genres as we're trying to participate in
the full heart fully you know and in
doing that we like to it's almost in the
characters in the movie are aware of the
same cultural references that we are and
so it would stand to believe that like
all that stuff would be on the table
basically and so so that's a big part of
the process is just lists of ideas tons
of ideas Jonah gets possessed someone
gets puked on they need water someone
steals the water someone doesn't like
the rules they try to make rules how do
they split up the food you just let this
into like a notebook could you put into
a word work or a dog or diamond well
sometime it's just like it's just a
running list there's yelling I think
right now with the latest idea we're
messing about with a 10-page we've like
a 10 page list and I think there's
another 10 pages we don't even really
and it's like it's like a relationship
type movie so there's like I did it just
like things happen to us and it's just
like Oh husband who holds back wife a
wife who enhances husbands yeah positive
madman it's just like it's also just
like housewarming party you think it's
things like that and like horrible go to
a party and something funny will happen
and you put that and it's just a stream
of consciousness collection and and
again and like and like that ideas
themselves as you go through these lists
over and over throughout the years some
ideas you kind of stick in your head and
you remember and some start to seem
stupid and you start to create
characters kind of based on the ideas or
sometimes you come up with the
characters first and sometimes you'll
just meet someone you'll be like someone
like that like someone who is going
through this in life for you know what I
mean
and it can come from anywhere and then
for
oh we got really and then process-wise I
think we kind of strayed a little bit in
that we got so busy we started kind of
like farming it out a little bit to
other people which is something that
we're kind of trying to not do is yeah
we wanted to do a lot of stuff and so we
had other people writing stuff for us
and it all worked out very well but we
got I think literally at the end of the
day if like the thing we are best at is
actually writing and and I think we kind
of stopped doing that honestly for a
while the opportunity to become
directors and that was so exciting
yeah that we just wanted to direct
another one and then we came and we were
becoming producers as well which and
like I mean and it was all kind of it
wasn't like a plan it was very organic
thing that was happening as our careers
were building and expanding into
different directions but as that was
happening
looking back our writing which is
probably the thing we're best at got
kind of pushed to the side a little bit
but now that we've done I think a pretty
okay job setting up these other things
our producing is going very well
our directing you know is established
and so I think we can refocus on writing
things and kind of settle back into what
we were doing and it's really exciting
too because the producing and the
directing cause this cycle where it was
like we got to get another one out
because we need to you know you direct
one movie you're not really a director
until you direct like two or three
things and then they're like oh this
guy's not going anywhere but now that
we've gotten past that hurdle we can go
back to what we really like which is
writing things and not rushing yeah
exactly
how did the first script you guys
collaborated on that got sold or got
made across that chasm Superbad yeah I
moved to LA to do Freaks and Geeks when
I was 17 just a quick interjection why
did they do a casting call it was at
your high school no it was with the
Vancouver okay
sometimes on is based in LA it was it
was it was based it was set in Michigan
it was shot in LA
but sometimes uh Judd and Paul judd
apatow and paul feig the creator paul
the creator and Judd the executive
producer of freaks and geeks
had a very they wanted real kids and
they had an idea from the beginning that
they wouldn't find the manila hand if
you're in LA you're like an actor kid
and that there's a good chance that you
were not what they're looking for that
being said I think they cast
I think everyone but me and one other
guy out of LA but so they were kind of
wrong but thank God they looked at least
because so what they did is they did
casting calls in Vancouver and Boston
and New York and Chicago and Toronto and
all these cities and I got to audition
in Vancouver and they were there like
Paul and Judd like we're in Vancouver in
the room and I recognized Paul Feig
because he's in this movie Ski Patrol
which I keep it rolling and so I see the
topless woman ski patrols not that pervy
there's maybe one and that's why I yeah
it's not it's not ski school but that
threw me anyway and so yeah and so they
cast me from Vancouver and I moved to L
I went there and shot the pilot and then
I came back and then it got picked up
and then I'm and so I was very lucky
because I like moved to LA like with a
job like I wasn't like one of I didn't
have to like go to LA and like try to
find work for myself like I went there
employed which was like at the time I
didn't realize like how many massive
hurdles I was overcoming just by doing
that you know what I mean and then so I
was there and then meanwhile we're
writing super bad and I give it to Judd
and Judd Judd was very busy at the time
running the show which was like going
down in flames basically even though it
was very good and so he kind of didn't
pay too much attention to it at first
but Jake Kasdan who was one of the
directors of the show who has gone on to
direct tons of movies and stuff like
that he directed the pilot of freaks and
geeks
hee hee really he's just like a very
nice guy who's around he was in his pony
he's very young and so he just like
really took a lot of time to like sit
with me and talk to me about it he would
give us notes on it and like it was just
very encouraging cuz he was like this is
good and you can keep working on this
and I was just at university in McGill
in Montreal the whole time because I
couldn't come to America even if I
wanted to because I didn't have a visa
his dad's America dad's there so I just
but I wanted to be a writer and it
seemed like via him on Freaks and Geeks
we had an inlet so I studied US history
so I knew who I was writing for better
understood Americans better I could
write better for Americans because I
knew that I knew Canadians and an
America is quite different yeah
but then after at some point judge did
read it and it was the during the show
we did undeclared so freaking he's got
cancelled and then because jut read
super bad he got another show going the
next year called undeclared which was
about college freshmen I was literally
the exact age of a college freshman and
so and he liked how super bad was
written so he hired me as a writer on
the show and so and then during
undeclared he really liked to like a
producer oriole role on super bad and
would give us tons of notes and try to
add that when we first started going
around trying to sell it that was in
like 2000 2001 and then 2002 yeah he
said bring your friend on down I'll
throw him a tiny bit of cash so he can
live and you guys should try to write
something else so I came down and we
spent two months writing pineapple
Express which he took he told us come
over the hundred ideas for movies we
just insane yeah we got 250 which is
great we ever made any of them and then
and then he was like these are awesome
but you should instead write a movie
about a pothead who's a process server
who gets hunted by his own dealer and we
said that's stupid
yeah and that will end a career before
it ever happened yes to be like a modern
Cheech and Chong and he just said but
what if it was good yeah we were like
Hello
we love action movies and you know die
hard and leave the weapon they were like
Oh what if we kind of make it like a 90s
like these nineties action movies that
we love so much and so we wrote
pineapple express pretty fast like we
just loved it it was our selves maybe
like six weeks or something like that it
was like one of those things where like
wake up at 3:00 p.m. right until 6:00
a.m. and we were very healthy was that
the time when we got a Costco card and
gained like 20 pounds we could get
passed in cheese because it was cheap so
so by the end of I think like 2002 both
pineapple Express and super bad were
written and just no one wanted to make
them and it would it would come closer
be so low we might make it and then it
wouldn't happen we might make it and
every now and then and like I didn't
have the money to do it I would fly down
we would go and pitch it or my dad would
drive with me from Vancouver and we'd go
and pitch it and every time we pitched
it probably 10 times Judd and Seth and
me would go and my dad would drop me off
and would go in and they'd be like we
love this is great and we're like okay
so you gonna make it and they're like oh
no we can't and slowly throughout this
process like I still remember the
beating we're like always I was like I'm
I'm gonna play Seth and then I remember
like it took so many years there was
like what meeting I was like I think
this is the meeting where I no longer
should say that because I'm 23 years old
so we these were studio heads or it's
studio exactly it was bold it was every
day it was it was some new companies
with like weird money that comes from
who knows where it was some studios it
was like every type of thing you could
imagine exactly when did the sort of the
the the other shoe drop and the positive
so meanwhile like we start getting work
we get hired on the Ali G show which is
great and it's just it starts to make
things like pick up a little for us I
was in the 40 year old virgin like
things like that started to happen I and
while he's an importer your Virgin jut
invited me to participate in some
capacity but I knew I had to finish my
degree so I could actually stay legally
so I finished my degree in Mis
out on that and by the time I came down
the premiere it happened and the movie
had hit yeah and so Judd started to
become a successful movie person like he
was now a director and writer and
producer an incredibly successful one so
an anchorman had come out and done well
which he was a producer on and then
Talladega Nights came out and did really
well and I think it was like Talladega
Nights didn't come out before we made
knocked up
we made knocked up first anyway we did
no I don't think so
I remember going with Judd to the
deville Film Festival I think for 40
year old virgin while he was here in
Atlanta I think shooting Talladega
Nights I'm bad with years in time but
this is approximately he would happen
and then around now it's like you know
when you get successful like Judd was
people just start wanting whatever you
have and so it was Sony was just like
we'll make stuff and so they made super
bad and at the time to make and however
much it was like 22 million like it was
it was it was a bizarre model that had
never been done no famous people
low-budget it was kind of an experiment
the studio was doing to see if they
could make big movies at a smaller
budget without famous and they also pun
of what's crazy is knocked up pineapple
Express and super bad were all made in
like one year I think basically like we
made them like back to back to back
because that was essentially like once
the floodgates opened we just like
shoved everything
statistically we're gonna be done in two
years everything and and then and then
knocked up knocked up and super bad came
out the same summer and both did really
really well and and so he was a
co-producer on for you a virgin yeah and
they made him an EP uh knocked up and
just made me an EP too which was bonkers
and I remember on the third day of his
first day on set he was an executive
producer Universal Studios comedy
laughs really hard because I was like
can I just take however much water I
want I was like hey what's up we've been
working together for like a week and
then she went up to set and was like wow
that guy's got a lot of energy he's got
great enthusiasm what was your reaction
even when you first found out that super
Brad was going to get made I mean was
that I mean I assumed I freaked out and
lost my mind remember was it night such
a blur because as he said it all went
down in one year it was just the most
exciting year ever but also for me like
he'd been working yeah I've been going
to school right which meant not going to
school and getting drunk and hanging out
with friends like I barely went to class
so I had this shocking shift from like
slacker student to working 14 hours a
day and I remember I would have to sneak
away and just like go into a bathroom
and sleep for like 20 minutes because I
wasn't used to it I couldn't handle it
thank you so much it was a really hard
transition for me but knocked-up was
kind of like boot camp yeah cuz jugde
you know it was his big shot to make
something really huge pushes oh we would
go 16 hours 17 hours 14 hours and I
almost lost my mind but by the end of it
I think I was like kind of
battle-hardened right conditioned for it
all and what what were some of the the
lessons that you guys learned have
learned from Judd I mean what are the
takeaways for whether it's the creative
process or I would say the biggest thing
we learned from him in my opinion is
like and and we talked about this
earlier don't keep stuff to yourself
like you're surrounded by smart people
bring them in get other people's
opinions share it with them yeah and
most importantly emotion is what matters
it's an emotional journey it doesn't
matter if the aircraft carrier hits the
skyscraper in two collapses on to the
hero it's what is he feeling when that
happened why does it matter that he has
to get out of the rubble yeah he just
taught us like emotion is the key like
the foreo version is a crazy weird movie
it's insane but it's about a guy who's
got like a wound yeah that he wants to
heal and through this journey he does
and it's all about that we
that to me in every k every character s
have a wound that's a big Judaism yeah I
think I mean about the process I mean he
basically like yeah like taught us the
process that we use a lot I mean
especially in regards to collaboration
and and in draw he he was somewhat
revolutionary in in how he did it like
people had done it before
like Christopher guest's and other
people but Judge figured out a way to
make improv and mainstream movies
collide in a way that I don't think
anyone know was really doing it like
that and yeah I mean the filming process
itself and how how to work on set is
something he taught us a lot about I
mean again and it's all it was stuff
that was partially figured out together
but he worked for years and years and
years before us and I mean it's so funny
and often I remember one time we were
filming the scene and knocked up I think
and improvising and he or maybe it was
even 40 over to the direction he
screamed at us because he screams
direction from another room a lot which
is hilarious but what he screamed at us
was less semen more emotion and I think
like that is actually like an
across-the-board good news
but I think it was just the area we were
riffing on but I think yeah I mean
whatever was saying exactly right like
the emotional core like what what is it
really about like and and and that the
movies and then and that movies can be
very sweet and still like and especially
if you're gonna make a movie that is so
like you know dirtier aggressively you
know you know filled with profanity and
that thing that like it helps if they're
sweet and if I really like if they're
not mean-spirited and if you and and and
write what you know it was a big thing
and try to inject your own like honesty
and experiences into your work even if
it's a weird spy movie or and again like
like this is the end is just about Jay
and Seth and Jay is upset that Seth has
found new friends and Seth is upset that
Jay seems to be holding on to the Past
that's what the movies about well has
nothing to do with the apocalypse really
that's just the the area it all went
down in yeah for when looking at
filmmaking or comedy movies specifically
if you guys could have written something
that someone else wrote and besides your
own stuff where you're like oh I wish
adaptation it's a masterpiece and the
script is even better the script is
great this movie I I think they made the
right choice with the changes they made
but the script is just longer that's
like one of those not a lot of movies
making like mind-blowing we jealous I
saw that out just like like five of my
best ideas like I was like oh there
should be a movie with someone has
anxiety represented by a character and I
was like oh he did this times better
than I ever could
plus ten other things that I had as a
whole was like funny and awesome like
it's just just the story of how that
came together also in terms of you that
he's hired to write
backstories is so funny and then I would
say on a flip side to me the most
magical emotional beautiful movies The
Princess Bride my favorite yeah I can't
watch it too much that was you know I've
had this fascination with screenwriting
even though I haven't pulled the trigger
on anything but the the screenplay that
did it was a Princess Bride reading
who's that William Goldman yeah yeah the
book on so good - great and all the
backstory it's the one of the scenes in
adaptation because you mentioned it one
of my favorite scenes is when he's
sitting in the movie Nicolas Cage
sitting in his apartment at this
typewriter he's like
what are your opinions of writer's block
oh we touched on this earlier I think
writer's block is complete [ __ ] like
it's a term people give to a bad week
laya
I have bad weeks I don't have writer's
block writer's block implies that like
you can't do it some things are just
harder than other things but I like like
you could have said that we had writer's
block on this is the end when we
couldn't figure out the third act I
don't call that writer's block I say
that was the biggest struggle this I
think that we just have never
experienced it which is why you don't
think it exists but I think that like
you think that we've never except no way
I imagine I think well I think what
happens to people actually we're just
lucky that we haven't experienced it is
they become uninspired like that I think
is what writer's block is and we're just
lucky cuz that has never happened us I
take issue with the term especially
block writers difficulties writers
writers writers block implies like it's
just not gonna happen but I think you
truly lose your inspiration or your who
you are as a creative person I think
people that experience those moments and
and that's writer I think that's what
writers do you think that what would you
tribute that do do you think that's
because you guys are writing what you
know or
when one of us is not doing great the
other one can pick up the weight yeah
when one of us is uninspired the other
one gives you like Romans from just like
I'll even know what the [ __ ] we're doing
anymore why are we doing this and then
he'll just have an idea if I have to
just keep going if then you power
through there probably over three he's
thinking the similar thing and I'm and
in that moment I'm not thinking that and
so it allows us to keep going yeah and
there's there's there's a beauty to
writing stuff on your own but
specifically for movies I think writing
as a team is extremely beneficial and
even if you do write alone you should be
sharing what you're writing with
everyone all the time all the time
because writer's block as some call it
and I would rather not solved by just
getting someone to help you write and I
think a lot of writers the biggest
problem I think writers have is they're
like I can't show people until it's
ready and then yeah that's popular I
think you need to show it immediately
I think talk about your ideas and I
think that's how if you have writer's
block that like there's probably a
reason you have it that's like a reason
you're uninspired and that is the thing
you should be writing about like I think
and I think in order to arrive at that
you need to talk to someone sometimes
like and I think that's why it's helpful
to have another person is like we're
very open with each other we talk about
pretty much everything that's happening
in our lives with one another and so
it's not like I just be sitting there
grumpy and he's like got Nadir's like no
I'm not feeling it today like like we
would I would explain why and that would
probably lead to an idea because we like
to write in that is that's why to both
of us adaptations the most genius thing
ever because a guy it's a movie about
writers a guy I took writer's block and
made it something yeah and I guess
that's my beef with writer's block is
like that's it's just something stopping
you but it'll put you in another
direction so it's still the path you're
taking who in your mind whether right
now you know alive or dead are the most
some of the more underrated comedy
writers well Hannibal Buress is a
stand-up comic he's not full yeah that's
writer but Batman is a unspeakable
genius Hannibal Buress Buress
hee hee hee started so Bill Cosby thing
yeah we have a guy we're working with
named Joe Mande bizarrely genius
I mean Garry Shandling is brilliant to
me like the Larry Sanders Show I think
in a lot of ways does a lot of the stuff
that a lot of people try to do there's
an animator who I think and writer who
one of the greatest geniuses to ever
live named Don Hertz
yeah he's amazing he made this thing
called rejected yeah that is the
funniest thing I think I may have ever
seen in my entire life
he animates by hand usually with a 16
millimeter camera he just started using
computers a little but uh it's it's he's
really it's like stick figures literally
and it's it's the most genius thing I've
ever seen yet he's incredible and yeah
he's probably not as lauded as one could
be I think he gets nominated I think you
want an Oscar action so never mind [ __ ]
yeah I mean I think like Matt and Trey
of South Park and Book of Mormon to me
are like two of the funniest humans ever
created
again Judd and I mean who who's like
like growing up I was really into I mean
sctv like Martin Short yes especially
kids in the hall and sctv played on a
loop in the halls like very was very
influential on us and we watched it a
ton growing up I've seen every single
episode like I never will turn on an
episode and it's one I haven't seen you
want to see what one that kind of
changed our lives Shirley Shirley
Shirley strangest and they did this
short I believe cause yes but what was
great about kids the whole is how insane
it was and like and it was and and and
at the time I didn't seem insane cuz we
watched it so much lately
got older and started to make stuff we
realized like I don't think I could get
that show on air right now you know it's
so it's so bonkers and the fact that
they got to do whatever they wanted even
though like two out of the five times it
was a big Mis yeah the other times it's
just like they nailed it yeah as they
got to do what they really wanted to in
their hearts and like we've got to work
with Lorne Michaels and I've got to be
around of a bunch and like that's one of
the things we talked about and he's very
proud of the show but he says I mean
he's like the key to that show was
letting those guys do whatever they
wanted and that was it he's like that
was that show was like they had to do
all of it because that's how crazy it
was we also we also had a well also
quickly Mel Brooks was like a huge
things Laura it's amazing I mean he's
not like known as being a writer by
trade or anything but he's a very funny
guy and like just like the Steve Jobs of
calm I mean he's it's unbelievable what
he's done and like he's someone that
every time I am around him it's like
it's truly like an awe-inspiring and we
also just from being in Canada we had a
lot of British television so we got a
lot of those high quality towers and
multi pipe are things that gave us like
a you know an attitude towards comedy
they have a family my parents are really
in a comedy and watch a lot of Woody
Allen movies when I was growing up and
like are there any late bloomers in
comedy writing who have not say known
since they were kids that they wanted to
be in comedy or in writing who have kind
of come on to the scene and done well
they've come to mind I mean that come to
mind there must be there must mean it's
a tough question but I figure no it's a
good it's a good one I can't think of
anyone more comedy directing acting in
Ferris
funny it's usually accidental I'm gonna
go with you on musk on that one of those
things where it's like and and I think
it's what brings comedians together it's
so funny cuz like whenever you go I
don't which I don't often but at the
times I do go to like a Hollywood type
party all the comedians are often like
lumped together in one little section
because they often all know each other
and and there and there and often
they're the type there's similar types
of people they for whatever bizarre line
and this is maybe over generalizing but
they comedians know that life is
ridiculous yeah and I think that's like
a common bond that holds them all
together well they're all like we're
never gonna figure this out this is all
absurd and yeah and let's kind of
analyze how repetitive party they're all
the people want to stand in the corner
and make fun of the party they're the
whole party is that Bryan Callen is bit
on the podcast nobody as a stand-up
comic oh yeah he's done a lot acting and
he gave me my first tour of the comedy
still he's in the 40 year old virgin
movie knockoff he gave me my first tour
of the Comedy Store and though the bunch
of the comics just ended up standing
outside basically making fun of the
party and video and shooting the [ __ ]
but that's not the real comedy is right
outside the car because you just think
it just but it could be more broadly
outside of comedy like Evan I'll ask you
first when you think of the word
successful who is the first person who
comes to mind for you honestly my cousin
David I got I got two cousins David and
Charlie who live in Orange County and
they just have a really nice note life
and three they're two great kids and
every time I go to their house I think
this is the most successful group of
people I know just because they're had
they're really happy and they all really
like each other and it's rare to have a
family that everyone likes everyone and
they're all proud of each other so corny
answer but my cousins Dale I just think
more people aren't like that or don't
have that
um I think they just made up their minds
I think other people deliberate too much
like they were just like he was like I'm
a doctor she was I'm gonna be a teacher
we want two kids we're gonna live there
and we're gonna make the best of our
lives and go to the beach whenever we
can they just like they seem to have cut
through a lot of the [ __ ] and made
their lives very simple in a beautiful
way and and it's all about their kids
and I don't know I just feel like they
are the most level-headed people I know
who have stuff like really figured out
stuff about yourself Michael Jordan my
parents I feel like seemed pretty happy
yeah I definitely don't describe like a
financial meaning to it I'm off the top
of my head yeah my parents are on a
cruise in Alaska right now eating they
just sent me a picture of a meal that
entirely comprised of tater tots and
beer so I'd say they're doing pretty
well right now dad has somehow made
vegetarianism unhealthy healthy
vegetarian but yeah my parents very very
happy honestly and and have always have
always seemed very like they're pretty
legs and I gotta say it which to me is
like a good a good place to be and what
I strive to be is is just a peace peace
with myself
do you Seth give books as gifts ever if
so I mean do you have a most gifted book
that you've given to people um I don't
give I give I give sometimes like like
coffee table type books as gifts but
like if someone's gonna move like I like
coffee cheese I'm not I read and I give
comic books sometimes to people I don't
often give books to people as gifts
because I'm not myself like a huge read
reading I'm not like a witch economy
have I given people I've given creature
to people I've given Watchmen to people
I've used I've given Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy to people because I love
that
and if they tell me they haven't read it
I'll give that to them I've given this
book the art of dramatic writing to
people because it's told us about your
book Judd gave us part of dramatic yeah
yeah if you're if you're a writer it's
useless and 40% of it is if references a
lot of plays that if you haven't read
and you haven't know who adds it just
does it a lot of it is very referencing
certain play the best part of it
explains the importance of premise and
how you must have a rock-solid one
sentence premise yeah before you die
thesis for the movie itself I remember
when John gave it to us he said it was
Woody Allen's favorite writing book
which was meaningful at the time and so
I've given that book to people
the conquest of happiness I've given to
people that's a great book that's by
Bertrand Russell it's like 1920 or
something like that actually great but
it's it's a great it's like one of the
og self-help books basically right I
think like the gist of the book is like
some say life is pleasurable some say it
isn't so I think about it and so I've
given those books to people yeah but not
I don't give a ton of books to people
and I know we only have a little bit of
time left but Evan what about yourself
give him
every new found every person who becomes
a mother who's a friend of mine I send
this Canadian child's book love you
forever - which i think is just love you
forever the number two or look however
it's a it's got a thing you love you
forever I love you for always as long as
you're living my baby you'll be it's a
it's like a mother and son and I think
that's a beautiful book that I give to
you it's but it's beautiful depressing
no one's been upset I gave it to them
really that not to you
a little prince is phenomenal
Hitchhiker's Guide and then I often give
preacher V for Vendetta and the Watchmen
to people but my main thing is love you
forever I think that like anyone who has
a kid should have that book now we were
talking about this briefly yesterday but
could you describe the habit that you
picked up from Snoop Dogg um over the
context we were smoking pot what
happened and and we were this is when we
were recording that song yeah and we
were hanging out with him and we were
smoking you out hoes come in when you
right now but he was like you like to go
for walks I was like not really really
he's like what do you mean I was like
I'll go for like exercise or whatever
but I don't just go for walks and he
looked at me really disappointed was
like you should you should go for walks
man that's a bad move you making a bad
mistake and it like haunted me that like
Snoop Dogg was disappointed walks so I
started taking a walk in the morning and
a walk after dinner and it has like
massively changed my life I sleep better
I have a better day because and I just
walk like ten minutes but he just kind
of went on like a little mini rant
saying like walking is great man it's
it's important I walk with my kids it's
one of the reasons people like having
dogs yeah you walk yeah Steve Jobs was
the famous Walker he was known for like
doing meetings on walks like instead of
like sitting in a office doing a meeting
he would they would walk around and wait
now I've started to become obsessed with
like I I will stretch during meetings
and I don't care who it's with yeah as
with you I will stand for full meetings
because I don't like sitting and we're
trying to get a new office and when we
do I'm putting a treadmill in there a
bunch of other stuff cuz when we're
writing I'm often just like walking
around the room like I pay sitting a
pencil in my should try a treadmill desk
um my friend has it it takes a little
while to used to I don't think I could
do that I've heard it's I've heard it's
good I saw someone running on a
treadmill reading a book at the gym this
morning it sounds like no one's written
a hilarious joke on a treadmill yeah
elevating desk that goes up and down but
I will try the treadmill what yeah the
key is not running if if you could have
given your seats let's just say 25 year
old self some advice what would you have
what would you've said I would have told
myself to lose weight I just lost like
25 pounds and I feel so much better and
my brain is so much sharper and I was
just I wasn't like massively overweight
but I was overweight for those from 25
to 31 and I was a very very big mistake
that was very fixable and I wish that I
could go back in time and be like just
start walking you start walking some
nice walks will fix this all and and and
I found out I was allergic to wheat so I
wish I could go back in time and tell
myself that six years ago I would have
had a lot better of a decade about
yourself says I was probably a lot
healthier when I was really doing better
by all means when I was 25 I probably
told myself to propose to my wife sooner
oh yeah that would have saved me and why
is that just cuz I waited I I don't know
probably not but it was probably like
what do they call that enabling I think
we probably enabled each other I was
like no I mean I don't have any major
regrets that have occurred between now
and then or any like I think those
lessons I've learned but they've been
valuable and organic to my living
process but the proposal III should have
proposed sooner that that I would have
done differently suppose this could be
it may be a similar type of question but
for you--even if you could have one
billboard anywhere that said anything
what would it what would be on it who
I've had a lot of billboards so that's
would you have a child right before
coming out November 24 I guess my
biggest beef with the world that I would
throw up on a billboard is uh this is
gonna get deep guys no except each other
whoa boom I don't accept that I don't
like when people don't accept one
another
I think they should and I would put it
on top of the Empire State but
people wouldn't see it very well the
entryway to the Empire State Building
accept each other's good I like that
accept each other accept me accept me
well I I know where we're wrapping up
here you guys have a lot in that case I
would like to when we leave we have to
go back to our job exactly a little bit
said I'd like to ask a couple of fan
questions this one is from Kyle Bailey
he wants to know about the future of
comedy and this is what he says on one
side of the universe creates a funny
reaction on the other side no one knows
why he says it seems to me that late 70s
and then 80s satire Saturday live
Seinfeld has led to all things funny
that has led to all things funny being
absurd hence Old Spice commercials
having minutes for so long seems like
the more absurd the funnier at least in
the mainstream when will the snapback or
when it leaks we experience in the next
direction of comedy or is absurdity the
final act of comedy and then somebody
added to that specifically on not online
where you're trying to grab attention
yeah you know distraction actually with
marketing specifically recently someone
told me that that now commercials like
actually do better if they make no sense
like that literally just like now do
commercial have you guys see that
mountain it's like the horse so no it's
like this horse to tell you like there's
literally like someone was to explain me
the theory where it's like the fact that
they make no sense actually makes you
pay more attention to them
then than a traditional commercial
narrative I actually don't necessarily
agree with that yeah it's not absurd
transparent it's not absurd like
trainwreck is one of the biggest
comedies of the year and it's like
completely you know us you know a very
grounded movie you know we love
ourselves an absurd comedy but our most
successful movie and in a lot of ways
like it goes it's it's quite broad at
times but in premise it's it's about
people who have a bunch of kids moving
next to them like it's not that bizarre
you know so I actually think I think the
biggest comedies are not absurd they're
they're somewhat grounded in reality and
and the less that the somewhat popular
but maybe less popular comedies like
this is the and which did very well but
isn't in the same universe as like
neighbors or trainwreck is doing much
better than like I think those truly
absurd ones actually don't do as well as
the more grounded ones it's like you
know memento I mean a not absurd but so
it's confusing to so many people I mean
I love lamento but it's been said of
kind of disheartening to find that a lot
of my favorite movies did very very very
poorly oh yeah we always say this like
like we'll never be number one and if we
are we won't be that cool anymore like
we always will have this sensibility
where it's like things everyone loves I
hate and things everyone ate I loved and
I'm just I and I don't mean that in like
I'm not trying to be like a hipster and
I do I also love a lot of mainstream
stuff and like I'm the first guy to in
line to see a michael baby yeah but fast
fast and furious is the greatest time
you could have it exactly but that being
said like there's some shows that are
really popular I'm just like I don't
understand why people like this and
there's some shows that no one likes I'm
like I don't why people don't love this
you know and and as long as you have
that Sensibility I think there's a good
chance you will not be the most
successful person along those lines of
Freaks and Geeks
looking back at that I mean it what and
this is a question from nip Nick Abreu
what was it about freakin geeks that
made everyone so successful in their
later careers is it would you attribute
to advice they received or more of a
networking effect or otherwise I'm
paraphrasing but I think honestly I mean
my hope is that that judge just and Paul
found people who happen to be very
talented and has the talent to sustain
themselves and they cast very well I
think they cast very well and like
having cast movies with Judd like he's
just got the eye man is just an
instinctual thing or is there do you is
there some get better at it it's
literally just there's not that many
really funny people and like when you
see someone who's actually very funny
like and if you're it's again we you
know you talk about it with investments
it's the exact like you start to hone in
on just like things that for whatever
reason you start to think like this is
good like and I think you you can train
yourself become more and more in tune
with it and I think that's one of the
things Judd taught us is like keep your
eyes out for that person if you're
watching a movie and someone is in one
scene and has one line and is funny that
person could star in a whole movie one
day maybe yeah like in the first
neighbors this is standup Jerrod
Carmichael who's in it you know has his
own show we're trying to write a movie
with our guys calendario for him to
story and it all just came from our
co-worker Alex saying I saw this guy
he's got it I think more than anything
that's what it is is that they he has a
very good you know Paul and Judd both
have very good eyes for spotty and
people that will that will keep work and
another thing is they look long and hard
like when we were looking for who was
gonna be the mclovin Fogel character in
Superbad it literally came down to
putting up signs in high schools Allison
Jones the casting director did own epic
search literally just putting up science
it does anyone know anyone who fits this
bill and his buddies were like you
should go that's cool do this that's a
smart approach so like I don't know a
hundred kids and that's just what we saw
you know filtered from the casting
director onto us and and and and it's
like a Hollywood cliché almost but when
you see that person you go it's him
that's the one yeah so just on McLovin
because this is this
came up surprisingly often so Justin 9a
Basti I think and then den GMO designs
I'm not sure ask them if they if they
would ever be willing to make a spin-off
movie about McLovin we are not but we
have discussed which will never do what
I'm about to say but we always thought
it would be funny to kind of do
something where you take Saul from
pineapple Express the James Franco
character and McLovin from super bad and
put them in a movie together but it's
never happy why would you never do it in
the same way that Donald Trump thinks if
he changes his hair he'll ruin his
career yeah to us like Superbad worked
it was everything we ever hoped it would
be and more and I'm not touching it I'm
not it's like if you throw two balls
last you're like now super bad and it
was bad it would crush me exactly yeah I
just I don't want to mess I couldn't
deal with that does of course weed comes
up a lot e what's that do you find it
helps creativity productivity neither
both I mean because they're questions
about like how do you beat you for you
two guys but what impact is it I would
say that it makes you a little Dumber
while you're on it
but for us you know no matter what job
you have no matter how amazing it is
it's work and we're in some ways sucks
and what we've tried to do at our office
like we have a big buck hunter in our
office and just taking five minutes and
playing around a big buck Hunter it like
lets you chill out going for a little
walk to get a cup of coffee well it's
been and for us and for some people it's
a very very bad idea I would say like
most people it makes them look so much
worse that they shouldn't but some
people it relaxed I think what's
important I think why it's helpful to us
is because it's what we do socially and
and so it makes work not feel like work
and I was I was actually just like
yesterday reading this thing that Isaac
like you it was an old article that
Isaac Asimov wrote about the creative
process that was just republished and
one of the things he talks a lot about
is is in his process how it's very
important to create like a casual
environment and it says like you
shouldn't work in an office you should
work in someone's living
in a restaurant and you should and you
need people who are jovial who so you
can who create a fun environment because
a lot of writing is failure and if
you're self-conscious that you're gonna
be rejected then you won't say your best
ideas and and I think again if it's I
think our thing happens to be smoking
weed with some people it's it's it's
other things but I think because it
makes our working feel like a not
working environment it makes our brains
function in a slightly more free way and
it makes us pitch ideas that maybe we
would feel we're too stupid to pitch if
we were in a more rigid environment and
it would make ideas like this is the end
not exist not because we're stoned but
because we are we're working in an
environment that feels very safe and
that feels very social and casual and
that and and that lets us pitch out the
ideas that might seem like the craziest
ideas you could ever pitch out but
because we don't feel like we're in a
work environment where everyone's
judging us and that we're wasting time
or not you know hitting the numbers or
quotas that we have to be hitting it's
it allows us I think to be more free
creation yeah like in our office right
now Seth has a bunch of paintings that
he's bought over the years from home and
he put them around and it feels like oh
that's yeah I like I like my yoga blocks
and my yoga straps and doing the
stretches to me is akin to the smoking
pot when you like the best
Caucasian squats I've ever seen yeah he
doesn't have the sitting position
usually he goes from straight standing
to perfect as in Japan that was about it
who goes what is the [ __ ] squad yeah
tell him what you bought me about Evan
like a platform that goes around his
toilet so he can squat
people listening to this should take
from this podcast it you should be
squatting when you should it's natural
it's better for you it's bad for your
back it's bad for your bowels and sit on
a toilet pop a squat
what do you guys use now I feel like
since you guys grew up in in BC they
eats for that is two pot as like growing
up in France would be to wine so is
there a particular type of pot because
I've had friends be like no man you get
anxious because of this you're using the
wrong foot we'll say those friends are
possibly correct I had somebody who was
telling me pots too strong I don't like
it it makes me anxious so I went to one
of the stores in California and said can
you give me some pot from 1995 and they
did and I gave it to the person and they
were like there you go the weakest like
what is the absolute worst weed you
could buy now is what the best weed was
when we were in high school probably
yeah we have a problem where people will
smoke pot with us and we'll be like take
it easy we don't smoke weak stuff yeah
continued smoking good weed but to get
name specific jack herer
yeah is a good working one there's also
good ones for work and ones that well
it's very simple there's sativas and
indicas and sativas are generally kind
of uppers and indicas are generally kind
of Downers and when you're working a
sativa is generally better because it's
not bogging you down there like a ninja
here or HP RR erhe are I think there's
one R in the middle but is there do you
guys have any just in closing ask or
recommendation of the people listening I
would say the the the reason that this
podcast is happening right now
is cuz with that guy Don heard felt I
mentioned there was one day Russ in
there I was like God what I would do to
talk to him and then I just picked up
the phone and called my agent I was like
can you get me Don Hertz felts another
and I talked to him and it blew my mind
and then I had the same thing with this
guy Sam Harris who I look up to here
America and I just called him and so I
reached out to you in the same way and
you write about this in your book as
well and I just
if you idolize someone or you look up to
someone or you respect someone's work
try to get in touch with them yes
there's no harm and so far I'm three for
three and I have an advantageous
position with an agent and all that
incredibly successful there's some guy
named Jordan who I ran into on the
street who I email with and he now works
at Funny or Die and I keep him in mind
and I don't know this guy from anything
he just came up to me one day on the
street and it's worth a shot
you never know like worst thing could
happen right well this Jordan guy could
kill me one day what no it's so true I
mean some fans of mine have you know
reached out to Warren Buffett and gotten
handwritten letters back from them yeah
you just never know yeah well it's the
same thing like sometimes like Seth and
I always talked about this we'll find
ourselves doing like an interview or
something and we look at each other like
why are we when did we agree to this why
would we do this yeah sometimes people
just drop their guards and agree to [ __ ]
you called the person on the one day
where their will is exhausted from
whatever else and they're just like yeah
man I'll be with you as long as I can
get off this phone calls just just do it
I mean like Nike you meet so many people
Nike
I mean Nike has the best tag line of all
time but um it's like we so many people
talk about writing movies and we did
write a movie and like you know my wife
wanted to make a movie and so she raised
a million dollars and made a movie like
it's not something that is completely
unattainable it's something that if you
are somewhat talented and have a lot of
determination and are willing to put
yourself out there and are willing to
fail then you can probably do something
more than nothing yeah and like in the
end
super bad was a success but like make no
mistake for ten years it was a failure
yeah and the first five drafts like if
you read them you'd be like this is the
worst thing I've ever read in my life
well told us over and over and over
again like I don't think I was really
and like it
didn't even occur to us to listen to
them like it wasn't even a conversation
of like should we stop like I literally
that we didn't even have that
conversation yeah it's like [ __ ] those
people let's go to the next ones like to
picture like Stephen King writing his
first book and me like man I'm stumped
yeah I'm gonna go be something else like
just go blind belief in yourself was
turned down 26 or 27 times also I mean
viciously like violently I have these
like angry sort of infuriated insulted
letters from acquiring it or turn it
down alright guys well let's I really
appreciate all the time let's wrap up
and we can do that with telling people
where they can find more about you guys
find you on the social webs and so on if
they want to say hi we do to a film
called the interview we're not as active
I'm about on Twitter a little a little
on your Evan Goldberg I'm Evan Goldberg
on Twitter Evan D Goldberg or Evan I
think it's been a while I will I will
put it in the show notes for everybody
also I'm Seth Rogen on Twitter and
that's Rogen with an ear and if you if
you write a letter and put it under the
second Oh in the Hollywood side or the
second dáil in the Hollywood sign
alright guys well thanks so much for
taking the time I really appreciate it
I've really listening of course thank
you for listening as always and for all
the show notes and everything else you
can go to 4-hour workweek comm spelled
out just click on podcast and until next
time thanks for listening thanks guys
thank you
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by athletic
greens I get asked all the time if you
could only use one supplement what would
it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day and you can get 50 oh my
gosh 50% off yes 50% off if you go to
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim check it out
it's tasty but more important it will
help you not screw up when you're doing
your nutritional planning so for me just
covers the bases takes a load off my
mind puts a lot in my body and check it
out athletic greens calm forward-slash
Tim this episode is brought to you by
Vimeo Pro which is the ideal video
hosting platform for entrepreneurs and
in fact a bunch of my startups already
use Vimeo Pro including wealthfront
who uses it to explain how wealthfront
works TaskRabbit uses it to tell their
company's story and there are many other
names you would recognize
among their customers Airbnb Etsy etc
why do they use it well Vimeo Pro
provides enterprise level video hosting
for a fraction of the usual cost
features include gorgeous high quality
playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week
unlimited plays and views and a fully
customizable video player which can
include your logo custom outro etc you
also get VIP support and you get all of
this for just $1.99 per year that's $17
a month with no complicated bandwidth
calculations or hidden fees and you can
try it risk-free for 30 days so check it
out
Vimeo comm forward slash business that's
VI m EO com forward slash business and
use promo code Tim to get 25% off that's
a special discount just for you guys so
check it out Vimeo com forward slash
business promo code tip if you want more
of the Tim Ferriss show you can
subscribe to the podcast on itunes or go
to for our blog com fo you are Hou are
BL OG com where you'll find an
award-winning blog tons of audio and
video interviews stories with Pete